are you going to vote for Matt Hancock  and I'm a celebrity  I'm not no  why not  well look I just think he should be here  looking after his constituents um yeah  you know rather than uh in the jungle  somewhere uh so uh no I won't be I won't  be voting for him although I can't  promise I'll be voting for anyone at all  so uh that that might just be a mission  rather than anything else will he be  watching though I mean are you looking  forward to seeing him having to eat  crocodile anus  tempting as that is I I think I'll  probably be focusing on my job as  business secretary uh and uh and I'll be  uh off at uh cop 27 later this week as  well so I fear I might miss him  depending on how long he survives once  again I see what you did